this is fast might this be the next
revolution an urban travel welcome to
Capital Bikeshare even better than the
excellent bike sharing programs that
cities allowed recently Washington area
these bike share bikes are great but you
got to pick them up in the dock here and
return them to the dock and just putting
these docks in costs hundreds of
thousands of dollars as so often happens
entrepreneurs invented something even
better than bikes that must be locked
into a dock dhoklas bicycles check out
the bike take it anywhere and just leave
the thing but just as I got used to
backless bicycles companies like Bird
and lime invented still and other
options electric scooters that people
can share they've scooted onto streets
across the country it's like a watered
down version of a motorcycle a new
two-wheeled battery-powered way to get
around to unlock a scooter you just used
an app on your phone for 2 bucks I can
jump on one of these things go where I
need to go and then just leave it
anywhere it stays here until someone
else rents it won't it be stolen no
because if someone tries to steal the
brakes lock off and this happened if the
thief took one anyway GPS device inside
the scooter would lead police right to
the thief the leave the scooter anywhere
system works it's a new twist on old
technology that entrepreneurs found to
give us something that works even better
to solve needs in dense urban areas
that's a wonderful thing if they don't
stop it by they I mean politicians many
cities banned the scooters a Bay Area
City at
San Francisco said they endanger public
health and safety
broken bones bruises and near misses by
these scooters 17 miles an hour
it hurts Who am I gonna sue when I get
knocked down it's been banned in San
Francisco which is particularly ironic
because San Francisco always seems to be
clamoring for more transportation
options they're complaining about the
traffic and they're asking particularly
for green transportation options in San
Francisco and many other cities scooter
companies tried to escape destructive
regulation by doing what uber and airbnb
did just put these out there and hope
that by the time the politicians notice
the scooters would be too popular to ban
they didn't get permission first and
that's the issue
unfortunately cities haven't learned
from their past experiences with
companies like uber and airbnb and they
want these innovators to come ask for
permission and go through the regulatory
processes you can take years years and
can also prevent consumers from
accessing a transportation option that
could be accessible now san francisco's
now granted permits to two small
companies but not lime and Byrd the
companies that started the business but
pedestrians say they're a hazard they
get up next two minutes till there are
safety issues this man reportedly died
after falling off a scooter and some
people ride recklessly
[ __ ] are you okay you're gonna running
us old people over we actually haven't
seen a large number of accidents are in
your injuries with these scooters some
people have been hurt and some people
get hurt but we don't see ourselves
banning bicycles because somebody might
get hurt on a bicycle there will be
social norms that evolve just like we've
seen with bike lanes then there's the
crazy opposition protesters say they
think the deluge of electric scooters in
San Francisco is a symptom of
gentrification this groups upset because
scooters are used by rich people tech
workers the scooters have provoked
intense anger here some people throws
scooters into the ocean others set
scooters on fire people vandalize these
at the low percentage of vandalism no
well I was just in another city the
other day and we had 10,000 rides and we
had 18 vandalism theft complaints so
when you think about people the
irresponsible media blows this off
whenever there's something new the media
always hyped the problem some people
call these scooters a nuisance which
makes it odd that this city Washington
welcomed scooters what I love about the
district is they are letting us innovate
in this space and they regulate
everything while not regulating us too
but in a very responsible way
good for DC not often I get to say that
one last twist so let's scan the
scooters even create new ways to make
money except yes
when scooters lose battery power scooter
companies pay people like this family to
find them pick them up and charge them
at home five to 20 dollars for every
scooter they charge what do you do with
the money
oh I'm invent I'm gonna try a new best
so kids make money people have a new
form of transport that's a green it's
good exercise takes up less space and
cars maybe just maybe the politicians
will leave them alone